President Donald Trump doesn't believe
FBI director James Comey that President
Obama didn't wiretap Trump Tower during
the presidential campaign allegations
were made by Donald Trump over the
weekend that without any evidence that
President Obama wiretapped Trump Tower
through a spokesperson Obama has denied
that former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper has denied
that the White House has provided no
Evan support its claim Comey has not
publicly addressed Trump's allegation
but we now have it from multiple media
outlets that James Comey asked the
Department of Justice to come out and
publicly say no president Trump's
accusation is absolutely untrue here and
asked by ABC's Good Morning America host
George Stephanopoulos if Trump was
willing to accept the denial of again
his own FBI director White House
spokeswoman sarah huckabee Sanders said
he was not saying quote you know I don't
think he does George I think he firmly
believes that this is a storyline that
has been reported pretty widely by quite
a few outlets the wiretapping has been
discussed in the New York Times BBC Fox
News and we believe that it should be
looked at by the House Intelligence
Committee the head of the executive
branch Donald is accusing the FBI of
lying and covering for a former
presidential administration this is not
normal this doesn't make Donald Trump a
tooth a truth-teller not a tooth teller
not a truth teller either it doesn't
make them a swamp trainer it doesn't
make them a patriotic cowboy the
president of the u.s. not only believes
path that Breitbart is inherently more
credible than the FBI he's willing to
say that publicly but I think his
supporters and even congressional
Republicans will go along with it
because they'll think that the president
is privy to information that maybe even
former DNI James clapper in the current
FBI director James Comey don't even know
but that's clearly not the case they're
in it when it comes to intelligence
matters that's disturbing it's also
disturbing for another reason which is
that after running his campaign
main on the idea of fiscal conservatism
and stopping government waste hard to
even keep a straight face from saying
that all that stuff Trump is asking
Congress to investigate a rumor that he
had a role in fueling right he's asking
for congressional time and taxpayer
money to go into what is an angry
statement on Twitter and it's not the
first rumor or a crazy notion that Trump
has called for investigations over the
three to five million supposed
undocumented immigrant or otherwise
illegal votes for Hillary Clinton
something that also didn't happen if
something that President Trump has
called for taxpayer money and
congressional time to go into when you
have a president that demands a daily
briefing that what that demands daily
briefings be presented in single page
form three to four bullets mostly
pictures and graphs this is the type of
thing you get taxpayer money going
towards investigating rumors that he
fuels on his Twitter account I just want
to point out that we've had our own
criticisms when it comes to FBI director
Comey shore because of the press
conference he had about Hillary's emails
and seeming to open the case up just
days before the election no doubt
appearance but we never questioned the
veracity of the claims that he was
making it was purely about timing so I
don't think that's a fair accusation to
make no doubt about it this is being
heavily discussed on our reddit
discussion forum I encourage you to join
us there david pakman.com slash reddit
that is david pakman.com slash r ed di t
back after the break gamefly is sort of
like netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
yet the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show
and support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s